when we used our energy principle
suppose we have an object that starts at
a height H naught and this object is
dropped and when it gets to the ground
it has some final velocity and when we
applied our energy principle assuming
that there was no air resistance what we
saw was that the change in kinetic
energy plus the change a potential
energy was zero so we had zero was equal
to Delta K plus Delta U and we saw that
the kinetic energy changed by one-half
MV squared and the potential energy
changed by minus MGH not so we can
compute the velocity of the object as
its falling given by square root of 2gh
not now now that we're considering
kinetic energy of rotation
recall that we showed that the kinetic
energy of rotate of a pure rotation
about a fixed axis was one-half the
moment of inertia about that axis times
the angular speed squared we now would
like to apply our energy principle to
include rotational kinetic energy along
with the translational kinetic energy
and the example that we want to look at
is something very simple suppose we have
a pulley
now our pulley has a mass P and we'll
say it has a moment of inertia of the
pulley about the fixed axis passing
through the center of the pulley and we
have a mass one and another block two
and let's suppose that we release this
system and for the moment let's make
this surface frictionless and suppose
that block two falls down a certain
distance so in the final state block two
will have dropped the distance H final
from
it's initial position and what we'd like
to consider is find the velocity final
of block two so we begin in the same way
that we've done this before by
considering our energy diagrams and so
we'll have an initial state and in our
initial state what we'll do is we'll
just have the initial one two and I'm
going to choose u equals zero here's my
pulley and everything is at rest and so
in the initial state the initial energy
initial K initial plus u initial is zero
and in our final state we have the
pulley is rotating with Omega final
block one is moving with the velocity V
final one and block two is also moving
with v2 final and let's just suppose
that this was our u equals zero position
and although it's so clear on the
diagram u final it has moved down height
H final so what is the energy in our
final state well we have to consider all
the different pieces we have block one
one-half m1 v1 final squared we have the
motion of block 2 one-half m2 v2 final
squared and we also have the kinetic
energy of the pulley which is given by
1/2 I about the pulley Omega final
square and what about our final
potential energy well we dropped the
height H final so we have block two has
moved minus em 2 gee H final and now we
have our two energy states
and what we'd like to consider is apply
the energy principle just like we
applied it for this simple case but
before we do that there is a constraint
condition that because the Rope is fixed
in length as block one moves the pulley
is rotating and block 2 is moving what
we'll have is fixed and not slipping so
as the Rope moves around the pulley the
pulley is moving with the same motion is
the rope and the Rope is moving with the
speeds of block 1 and 2 so we see that V
1 final is equal to B 2 final and now
what about the pulley if this is radius
R we know that the velocity of a point
on the rim of a disc is moving with the
speed of the rope which is the speed of
block 1 and block 2 so that's our Omega
final and so that makes our final energy
that's now gather terms the velocities
are the same so we have one-half m1 plus
m2 and we'll just call this V final for
simplicity one-half m2 times V final
squared that accounts for these two
terms and we have the moment of inertia
kinetic energy associated with the wheel
which is one-half I Omega final squared
which is V final squared over R squared
minus em 2 gee H final and so now we can
solve our energy principle which is
because we're assuming everything is
frictionless we have 0 equals e final
minus initial implies that a final
equals the initial and we chose our
initial potential energy to be zero so
of course that's just a choice of
constant so I can now solve this
equation
by setting a final equal to zero that's
the same statement and then you can see
algebraically I can solve for V final
and what I get is I'm just going to
write all these terms over I get em 2
gee H final I'm gonna divide by this
common coefficient 1/2 + 1 + M 2 plus
the moment of inertia divided by radius
squared and I now have to take the
square root of the whole thing and
that's how I can find the velocity of
block 2 when it's dropped down a certain
distance H final so here we've
generalized our energy approach to
include rotational kinetic energy